they are called Europe's Shadow Army
operating without an official name
leader or government link
former Greek officials say these masked
individuals use Force to try to keep
refugees from entering Europe through
Greece
verified footage off the coast of Greece
shows members of The Shadow Army
damaging boats carrying refugees and
beating others no doubt no shadow of a
doubt that these crimes are taking place
these are orders
coming from the top with the consent of
the European Union
which are being implemented which are
being carried out
by hapless members of the Greek Coast
Guard we've have cases where refugees
were found drowned handcuffed
many in the shadow Army are believed to
be refugees themselves bribed with the
promise of asylum in return for their
work to keep other migrants out
the Greek officer who interrogated me
told me very bluntly you have two
options you either follow our orders or
go to prison where you face 10 to 25
year sentence
other images show men being assaulted
for not wanting to take part
when I refuse to join them they beat me
up they stripped me of my clothes and
threw me into the sea several human
rights groups accused the European Union
and States like Greece of supporting the
shadow Army as a way to keep refugees
out we have
tens of thousands of people who report
the same thing happening the
institutions of Europe the European
Union
the Greek government
and other governments are committing one
Crime After the other Against Humanity
they've turned the Eastern Mediterranean
into a watery grave on purpose
Greek officials say these allegations
are not true and insist their efforts to
stop undocumented migrants from entering
Europe through Greece are legal is the
Greek Coast Guard actively pushing back
migrants in the Aegean Sea
absolutely not we fully abide by
International and European law we are
building a bigger fence we're blocking
the whole land borders with turkey and
hopefully that will get a lot of
it will make it much easier to protect
our external borders at least one
million people have tried to enter
Europe illegally through Greece in
recent years
but many find themselves trading one
form of uncertainty for another
the risk of drowning starvation and
violence Mars their Journey from start
to finish and can end with no new place
to call home
Leah Harding Al Jazeera